[Music]
thank you
hey what get that shot
needed one in the Fairway Trevor and got
one there from Patrick Mahomes little
Club 12 off to that too
oh yeah look at this look at that
man Patrick Mahomes dialed in here early
so when you get to 85 do you just pick
up of course after the whole nine or
what did you go how about that shot from
The Mulch there just a little bit
there's a ridge right here you can use
Ernie here we go
that's pretty good right really good
shot
I'll give us a fighting
to that he throws it a little bit in
transition it can't always come
control the club face but this is good
right here is it gonna make it come on
nice shot
oh nice piece that's good uh I'm a
lightning fan but shout out to the TNT
people Wayne gretz getting those guys
man I watched that entire hockey game
last night it was amazing how good was
that game that was great wasn't it was
that shot right there how about Patrick
Mahomes
oh
oh walk that in won't you
oh
sting it
stay in the Fairway here I'll give you
some short grass
nice shot all right
cut
Kick It Off
oh buddy
two beauties nice shot
oh nice pot
big I don't even notice those people I'm
just looking at Fairways and pins tunnel
vision
aim small missile
what's your availability next week uh JG
uh after I get off TV today I'm
absolutely free for the next four months
perfect that's going to feed back oh
what a shot and it's getting better oh
that might go in that might go in
and forget these guys are one up
wow this is huge because they can keep
their noses in front if he makes this
coming back up the hill
solid man he's been solid
Nice Shot gotta stay there
stay there Market oh
oh here's my home soon
almost had it on that upper shelf
oh
my god oh you're wrong
heads up
oh that's good yeah
he's gotta go
oh boy
all right oh boy
in front of the green in a long way away
come on one time
one time for the lake got the speed one
time
that's the bullet then